mmm next game with white with the
dreadmaster from from Poland let's check
with you who that is marks in shubab
2600 almost okay don't know it just
shows how many strong grandmasters down
okay let's see what we get here night
off ok this is this is sideline this is
some bad news for me because I only know
some main lines a bit cannot see 5 might
be the idea so I'm gonna try to do
something about the e porn maybe just a
form so that I have Bishop f3m okay now
he goes back to some sort of Dragon set
up till
maybe it's an idea Queenie to the idea
of playing a 5 not sure I try that the
key at least needs to do something about
that the e5 idea okay plenty five
himself I thought this would be maybe
risky because of the porn okay
interesting position should i spend a
move to play a form i'm not sure maybe
you can play something like d5 and
really blast open the position with my
queen of the kingdom on the same mum the
line not sure if i might also just play
em click b6 at some point can play
somewhat faster he have already spent
two minutes okay you just played
something entirely different this looks
like pretty yeah normal position d6
seems a bit weak though very often in
this kind of structures the bishop is on
e seven of course there is more passive
compared to g7 but at least it always
protects the pawn safely okay it's
certainly not the end of the world for
black but still okay i know i don't like
possibility of all these checks so let's
drop this piece back Bishop c4 Coliseum
okay always have 95 not sure good it is
though
ok let's go 95 it's not the move I
wanted to play doesn't really help with
this porn issue now it is safely
protected or let's say it is not the
weakness anymore now this should be fine
for black no or maybe it was before as
well but this is a standard position
which is okay you get this kind of
structure very often in the night off so
we certainly will know what to do we try
to provoke f6 okay this is it an idea to
exchange this bishop don't think so
now it still still looks fairly solid
for white think
but hard to make make any progress
cannot play we should be too let's cover
c1 safely bishop is not doing much
anyway on h6 and I'm really down on time
okay that's surprising I thought this
was some really bad piece on f3 I just
see something does he have something on
concrete here some critics the back rank
may be back rank rookie one of d 1 I
don't see a brilliant trick here okay
let's take this but there must be some
tactics otherwise this is complete
nonsense rookie to maybe I are f7a
saying no no no also rookie what is also
complete this doesn't make any sense as
well so what what what is he doing here
isn't this just just fine for me now I
think so only am down on time as usual
okay can't take fri morning it's getting
the night down this is of course not to
very welcome
not so easy to make moose here so it is
just a ticking this poem
don't see a good one actually really
you
you may be just outplayed me possible
check
Kim nie Dage five nice trick I could
have just taken her okay I was lost on
time anyway forfeits on time yeah this
was somewhat strange I didn't understand
this year okay gets he may be gets the
night the night on it the night only
forward I still don't believe it I just
played just played badly I think here it
shouldn't be so bad would be surprising
if it was I think okay it's got the open
if I am maybe maybe I need to play a no
Bishop g5 or something prevent Knight f6
it's not not the position type i have
often camp maybe this was was really
okay for blacken it's possible i don't
think i would have played this way but
yeah one issue might be for black hear
that he's got so many pieces that like
to be only five that he simply has got
too many of them so maybe this wasn't
also 18 IDM possible
taking with a night not sure where you
can exchange Queens we had some what
we're talking maybe it's just okay
public can be computer also assess
blacks better here so you might simply
get the night here and then it's gotta
find position yeah okay next one